let's talk circles all points on this
circle are equidistant from this point
which is called the center of the circle
this session covers just the basics of
circles something many of you would
already know the distance from the
center to any point in the circle is
always constant and is called the radius
of the circle no matter where you draw
the line from the center to the boundary
the distance will always be the same a
line segment like this which passes
through the center is called the
diameter it passes through the center
and its end rest on the boundary of the
circle and as it can be seen from the
figure its length will be twice the
radius of the circle moving on another
concept we need to know is that of
chords in circles they are line segments
which have the end points lying on the
boundary of the circle like this one or
this one both are called
chords as the end points lie on the
boundary of the circle let's go back to
the diameter the endpoints of the
diameter also lie on the boundary of the
circle so is it a chord - yes it is but
a special one it's the longest chord of
the circle the length of the chord as it
keeps coming towards the center
increases and is maximum when it passes
through the center the next concept is
pretty interesting when we draw two
radii in a circle what we get is a
sector this region in sight is called
the sector of this circle look at the
sector carefully it is bounded by two
radii and this green curve and this
green curve also has a name it's called
an arc it is simply a part of the
boundary of the circle we can call it
arc AC B so this sector is bounded by
two radii and an arc ACB and the last
concept in this session is that of
segments no we are not talking about
line segments here a cord divides the
circle into two segments let's call this
cord a B we mark C on this side and D on
the other as this region formed by the
cord is smaller it's called the -
segment and you would have guessed
already that the other region is called
the major segment segment ACB is minor
and segment ADB is major and similarly
in the previous figure this one is a
minor sector and this one a major the
green arc ACB is a minor arc and the
remaining portion of the boundary is the
major arc now that the basic concepts
are clear let's try building on it in
the next few sessions
you